JASON SILVA: There
are people who
talk about the creative
process with such humility.
There's a sense that
something larger than yourself
has worked its way through you.
To paraphrase Kahlil Gibran's
notion about children,
the creative
process-- creativity
comes through you
but not from you.
Though it is with you, it
belongs not to you, right?
This notion that we are the
frontal lobes of the universe.
And so when we
craft beauty, when
we vocalize, when we
utter inspiration,
what are we actually doing?
Are we creating something
that isn't there?
Or are we merely
transcribing, right?
The notion of inspiration means
we're breathing in and exhaling
what we've taken in.
So we're merely transcribing
the observation of what is.
We're recording.
We are all cosmonauts,
psychonauts.
And the creative
process is merely
what we brought back as
reporters of the numinous.
When we go to Plato's realm of
ideals, we are as navigators.
We are as Dorothy going
into Oz, seeing the world
through a different
lens, seeing reality
through a different operating
system, a different set
of filters, and thus being
able to read differently,
to see something that others
can't and then bring that
back and then share that back.
And I think that that's what's
happening during creativity.
And I think that that's why
we should be humble about it.
Respect the gods.
There's poetry in every moment.